[Music]
[Music]
he wants to marry me
i want to marry her yeah i'm happy aki
did i go behind you
behind her father's back did i go behind
your back and do some messy
dodgy things like it did i go and do
that no i was straight up i came to you
guys
on a serious note aki the process of
suddenly said if a righteous man comes
to ask your daughter's hand
and if you reject them they will fit
them in the land aki
i'm coming to you guys in a halal wayaki
i'm asking for your daughter's hand
i'm asking your father aki and i'll be
rejected for what
for what brother tell me what why am i
doing something haram i gotta go and ask
for a number did i say let's go link up
did i say let's go and do this this this
aki everyone's doing all kind of madness
committing zina
did i go and do this my brother i came
on a note but your
your dad is rejecting based on what my
brother is
[Music]
the journey to marriage is filled with
uneasy excitement
a special moment of a person's life
a dream being finally fulfilled
those sweet warm whispers
long romantic walks and as they say
a life with a special person until death
do us part
well my story is quite different
[Music]
oh and wait till you see how my story
[Music]
ends
foreign
[Music]
so guys that was the trailer now follow
me
because i've got a lot to share with you
guys because this is just the beginning
and i'm going to tell you why
it is just the beginning in this
marriage documentary brothers and
sisters you guys have been waiting
for nearly three years yes in a couple
of weeks time it's going to be
the day that i actually had manika
yes there's a reason there's a reason
why it took so long
three years there's a reason allah
subhana wata knows best but the first
lesson that we learn
from this is that patience is key and
believe me through my search
and what i went through patience is
something you must
must must have while looking to get
married brothers and sisters
what i'm going to tell you now is that
everything that's going to be covered
in the marriage documentary yes
everything from the uncle rejecting me
to me wanting to travel to somalia to
the
most awkward question that was asked me
from a sister and she put it in other
words of how big
your feet is um yes i'm sure you guys
know what i'm talking about
how i dealt with that why that was asked
to me we're gonna find out because i was
as surprised as you guys are and maybe
as disgusted
but may allah forgive her we're also
going to be discussing a variety
of other topics i'm going to take you on
a little journey
where we're going to be talking about
these matters because marriage is such a
big topic and it's such a big fit now
because something that is halal has
become haram
we're going to be talking about what
kind of questions can you ask the sister
you want to marry
or the sister i want to ask you what if
the father doesn't
accept you what rights do you have as a
person who is following islam
what is your right we're going to be
talking about me
wanting to marry a divorcee sister with
kids how did that go
i'm going to tell you guys also about
people that i hurt in the process yes i
did
why am i telling you this because i'm
not perfect i'm not going to give you
this
illusionary imaginary person ali dao is
no
there's mistakes that i made
unintentional mistakes that i made
and it caused people's emotions to be
hurt i'm going to tell you lessons of
how what i learned from that
why and how we can avoid that we're
going to be talking about can i talk
on the phone to the potential that i
want to get married can i text them is
this allowed can i ask intimate
questions
can a sister ask a brother how big his
biceps are how
you know what his wayside is can a
brother see the sister he wants to marry
you know in a bit of certain clothing
that she can wear that can give him an
idea of her body she is this allowed
what kind of questions can you ask are
we talking about different ways and
avenues of looking to get married one of
those was
one of one of those was that i came to
turkey yes came back to where i am today
to look for marriage why did i do that
social media instagram facebook snapchat
twitter can we approach someone
there marriage meetings how about if i
saw somebody
on the street that i like we discussed
this with mufti mink how do i go about
it you know am i supposed to follow it
to a house
what do we do we're gonna be talking
about the suicide of my cousin
images of that on his deathbed we're
going to be talking about
the damages harambe should bring i'll be
talking about istahara
how do one how does one do is some
people think it's a dream i saw nutella
a chocolate in my dream
and it means it's a sign that i should
go ahead no we're going to be talking
about marriage scams
we're going to be talking about those
who give false promises and the family
do not tell you
what the person you're marrying is
really about and you
fall for this marrying this guy or this
girl who is not what they show
and you are falling for the scam and
they ruined your life we're gonna be
talking about going inside the man's
brain for 24 hours
what goes through his head we're going
to be talking about we're going to be
talking about the wally we're going to
be going undercover with certain aspects
of certain
matrimonial sites and show you the
reality behind them do i recommend them
i'm going to be telling you guys showing
you guys my account that i had on
matrimonial sites which you're going to
see
what i saw there'll be a lesson for the
brothers
for the brothers yes because i learned a
lesson myself
we're going to be talking about talaq
how
to avoid divorce we're going to be
talking about divorce we're going to be
talking about
how to prevent divorce we're going to
talk about the stigma behind divorce the
sisters that i look down upon
not as much as the brothers we're going
to be talking about all kind of
questions
the first night yes you are going to
learn an
absolute lesson from a to z of
marriage inside and out not only that
we're also going to be preparing a
website called makemynika.com.com
and you're going to learn from there the
process that i've prepared for you guys
absolutely free absolutely free some
services yep they're different those who
get married that's different story
but absolutely free so we're going to be
talking about that aspect of it as well
questions can you marry a virgin yes a
brother
can you request is he a virgin can you
request a sister can you know about this
is this allowed is this a sin
how to avoid those players those guys
who manipulate and
use you how you can protect yourself
i've developed a formula
that will help you inshallah from the
quran and the sunnah nothing from myself
inshallah
and how we can implement that to protect
you from heartbreak how to get over
heartbreak if you have committed sinner
how to repent
what's the procedure of repentance what
you need to do how not to go back
you name it from a to z brothers and
sisters
but inshallah it's going to be an
exciting journey and on the first
chapter we go back
to my haram relationship years ago i was
in that relationship for five years
alhamdulillah allah protected me from
major things may allah protect us all
i'll be going back and speaking to a
mother so inshallah embark on this
journey with me it's been three years
you've waited
the time has come we are going to make
sure like allah subhanahu wa
subhanallah says the quran do not even
come close to zina
because it's full of evil and this is
what this whole marriage documentary is
about
get your pens and papers ready because
we are about to embark on a journey that
is going to take us
to a good place and inshallah our lord
will be pleased with us
also we have set up a system called make
a website makemynika.com.uk or
makemoneycard.com
where we have prepared for you guys a
practical steps
of going about it the right way the
halal way of finding the right partner
and avoiding the haram we've got
precautions in place
and you can totally absolutely free join
get involved and i will be soon very
soon sharing that with you inshallah
where you go onto our
website make your marriage cv download
it however you like it inshallah
and if somebody wants to get to know you
we will show you
practical methods and ways of going
about that and
just to finish off i want to thank
giftos restaurant
may allah bless him he believed in this
project he helped this project because
one of the reasons why i couldn't bring
this to you guys
is because financially i couldn't do it
i couldn't try to put invest my own
money into it
he believed in it human relief
foundation um
muslim box company
mini muslim and also black oat these
brothers and many other the shuffle
company all of them anyone that i've
mentioned forgive me but these are the
main groups that
inshallah help him to bring the
documentary to you but most of all gift
restaurant may allah bless him not only
the food is nice
but he believed in us and with him
inshallah he will get the rewards of
helping us
to inshaallah come in unity in a halal
way assalamu alaykum